Gamers' Ground Zero, the Electronic Entertainment Expo in Los Angeles...
...and Sony and Microsoft go head-to-head.
In an aggressive move, Sony has priced its new PlayStation 4...
...substantially below its rival's Xbox One.
The Japanese company also said that its console will run secondhand games...
...and won't require an always on internet connection, unlike Microsoft's.
Allowing Sony to crow,...
PlayStation is synonymous with gaming, that's our DNA.
We've always put the consumer first and obviously we're for-profit company,...
...we're in business to make money,...
...but if you make the consumers happy, the consumers will respond with loyalty.
And I really think we focused on that consumer value...
...from the first PlayStation that we ever put out there...
...and we've never wavered from that.
The markets reacted in a similar way to the gamers.
Sony's shares rose, Microsoft's fell.
Both companies are hoping their latest offerings...
...will attract new fans and retain users...
...who are increasingly playing games on smartphones and other mobile devices.
Both will have their consoles in the shops before the year-end holidays.